[Applaudissements]
gagnant mais je parle d'un combat et
revient d'accord la ce a rappelé jean
michel maire pousse à regarder clash
pour soir vers les classes juillet 98
finale de la coupe du monde de foot
ouais je faisais pas ça partait à aucun
service était journaliste à france soir
j'apportais n'a aucun service concerné
par le match de foot mais j'avais mal
compris tout du journal étaient
réquisitionnés pour un événement comme
ça j'aurais pu comprendre
bon du coup on me demande de faire de
participer alors j'avais prévu une
soirée chez moi avec tous mes potes
devant un écran géant pour regarder le
match est en fait je me trouve
réquisitionnés ou en seine-saint-denis
dans un gymnase pour regarder le match
et donc qui grillent tu peux m'asseoir
avec mes potes dont je m'embrouille de
ouf j'ai essayé de virer d'ailleurs
l'occasion avec le directeur la
rédaction ne françois je me retrouve en
scène ce n'est dans un jeune âge à un
autre hassan sony mise dans un gymnase
tout le monde bat pourquoi été pour le
brésil n'ont donc tout le monde était
beau le brésil dans succès en bois de
boulogne
[Rires]
ouais tout le monde était pour le pour
le brésil bizarrement et c'était un an
+8 schéma qui avait réquisitionné pour
diffuser le match ou un petit à petit
dans le gymnase et dès la fin du match
au coup de sifflet final tous ont été
notamment déçu il a débranché la télé
non écran noir dont j'ai pas vu la
remise de la coupe j'ai absolument rien
vu je rentrais au journal sont encore
brouiller que directeur j'ai écrit un
journal qui n'a pas pied qui n'est
jamais passé parce que c'était pour dire
qu'en fait le tour on était bon le
brésil le papier n'est jamais passé ça
me flinguer ma coupe du monde j'ai même
pas vu la faute d'un triste c'est bon
ouais mais bon c'est pas une grosse
ombre ou non non non parce qu'elle est
là dans les deux cas les deux là les
deux là ils vont avoir des grosses
embrouilles là on dirait garder on
dirait le père et sa fille de votre mère
origines verdez un peu vénère comme ça
c'est vrai on ne connaît pas son père
mais je sur qui doit il doit non ça bien
même région tout ça et bien sûr mais la
famille et tout mais c'est pas vrai bien
bien sûr et à l'ordre et au savon
quatre mois la famille afin d'y n'êtes
pas d'accord
bien sûr j'ai dit ça au hasard
oui sur une coupe qui se passe tout le
temps devant chez elle je suis de là bas
et tout ça alors je connais l'entraîneur
de foot de ma vie non c'est on est on
est on est on est d'accord voilà six ans
après votre oncle sans rigoler les yeux
alors tim kelly christine kelly mc
cotation briller des écoutes première
pas du tout aimé oui ben en fait mon
clash a été silencieux je me suis levé
et je me suis et je suis partie du
studio d'europe 1 c'était en octobre
2009 je lègue avec laurent baffie
je les regarde et je regardais et je
veux raconter entre les lieux-dits aura
pas non plus refaire le monde la
signalétique existe déjà et elle a le
mérite d'exister c'était l'an passé de
rejeter de ne pas éduquer son enfant de
ne pas dire bon j'aime ce que demandent
ces dames c'est simplement que vous
l'entendiez et que vous lui disiez
peut-être oui vous avez raison nous
allons été essayé d'étudier la question
la signalétique a le mérite d'exister on
peut pas la critique et elle a déjà le
mérite d'exister couilles et que tout
est dans un cadre de critiques méritées
en fait c'est d'améliorer ça améliorera
ballon c'est parfait
non enfin boîte à une embolie d'aulaqi
va pas le direct a dit n'avoir pas
demandé pourquoi je suis parti je n'ai
jamais dit dix ans plus tard je vais
vous dire pourquoi je sois pas dit que
nous parce qu'il avait un programmateur
qui m'avait supplié de venir à cette
émission
j avais dit non j'adore les filles ont
finalement on m'avait expliqué comment
l'émission serait pas où est le
président du csa n'ouvrait pas que j'y
aille personne ne voulait que j'y aille
j'y vais au m'expliquer comment ça se
passe une émission pas en direct pas
d'interview au téléphone excellent
contexte et après finalement l'émission
dépend de ton te donne quelqu'un au
téléphone tu sens que c'est de la
magouille
tu sais pas comment ça soit tu sais pas
quelle copine de qui appelle est
vraiment c'était pas du tout ce qui
était l on y vote à graphiline
maintenant l'ado a lancé ce qui est
rigolo c'est que le lendemain il
m'envoyait un bouquet on est entraîneur
on était potes avant on était en brasse
mon lolo va là jusqu'à mardi la très
libre et luc super compris vous a sauté
dessus a nommé mme ont tous sauté dessus
alors qu'en fait c'était une sorte de
coup monté contre un membre du csa
c'est ça le truc groupe personne n'ose
s'attaquer aux saisons avec les 3
millions prison ils peuvent avoir de
très bons avocats
oui bonsoir soir comme vous le savez je
ne suis pas le roi du clash champ de la
nation devait les mener mais au masculin
c'était drague rendra sera rappelé à
frapper comprennent séduire une fille a
le copain qui démarre qu'à te rappelles
je suis pas laissé démonter alors non
franchement autant mairie connaît pas
s'il vous plaît comme je regarde regarde
et puis on prendra les monty et c'est un
bon tu fais tout aussi dentaire je fais
ici tu fais quoi mais comment je fais
quoi ici ceux qui sont clos c'est là
c'est la folie tout en muscles ou pas
bush ne pensait pas totale
c'est lui
dallest
et d'abord nord
tu pas besoin de ça pour toi
[Applaudissements]
le
toujours temps de sortir
[Musique]
ces dégagements sont quelque temps la
trace en photo
hier laurent neumann barca dans un
panier d'osier quand elle le top avec le
trou et qatari n'avait pas vu ça j'avais
pas vu qu'alizé novelli c'est quoi votre
moule ou alors c'était le 14 février
derniers mois pour la saint valentin
ouais si chez fleuriste la boulogne à
côté ouais chercher un prix attrayant
pour matthieu delormeau way et j'ai mis
ma voiture en warning ouest juste devant
le fleuriste pour aller vite je me suis
dit que ça allait aller vite et en fait
ça a mis plus de temps que prévu parce
que tous les maris étaient en train
d'acheter des faveurs à leur flamme et
donc du coup j'entends une dame une
personnage écrit dehors qu'ils étaient
dans le quartier oui mais moi en mode
curieuse je mets ma tête est en fait
serment qu'elle s'adressait nom et elle
m'a dit vous vous prenez pour qui avec
votre voiture en warning
je vais vous crevez vos pneus petite
conne non apparemment elle vous
connaissez ces retours neigeux et
d'imagés vous crevez autre chose vieille
conne nos polices non mais là je me suis
dit bon j'ai pas le temps plus tard tard
pour venir ici et donc je suis parti
mais morale à cette histoire c'est quoi
c'est pas parce que nous sommes des
personnes âgées
je m'adresse à toutes les vieilles dames
et à tous les vieux à gauche à gauche
vous n'avez pas l'immunité vous n'avez
pas le totem vous ne pouvez pas vous
permettre de parler mal aux gens ce
parce que vous êtes vieux qu'on va pas
vous tapez
[Applaudissements]
chanter et fait tourner bien à l'aller
certaines sorties et le reste mais ce
n'est pas parce que les personnes âgées
ne nous reste qu on respecte d'assurer
les affaires sales âgées oui a bien
entendu et on ne tape pas les
personnages etc et gilles on est
d'accord
oh là là jamais jamais jamais mais à
côté d'un clash comme ça le mien va
paraître dérisoire
on n'attaque personne d'ailleurs voilà
on ne tape personne violant viaggio
lopez dans le public est là qui est un
ami voilà il est d'accord et moi
maintenant de ta personne veut ou pas jo
voilà merci de ta personne et kelly
savent ça ça va pas oui alors moi j'ai
choisi un des clash que j'ai eu sur le
plateau cette voie et classe les plus
loin non j'ai pris celui avec patrice
carteron allemands appellent donc on
s'était un peu embrouillé ont fait des
bonds il est marrant on peut regarder
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
diouf est gagnant mais je parle d'un
combat et revient d'accord
[Applaudissements]
sa part à garder occupés ni
ouais ensuite je pensais bien tu le sais
bien
vous étiez un peu inquiet quand même
avoir regardé en me demandant de me
calmer vous saviez pas s'il avait pas
d'eau non il est cool quoi vous êtes une
bonne bagarre après non non non et puis
après il m'a fait un petit message tout
ça ouais ça j'irais bien le voir
combattre le voir perdre c'est son
problème
[Musique]